foreign
[Music]
on this Friday night Russia renews its
attempt to capture Ukraine's Capital new
bombardments in and around Kiev
packed houses for Pierre Palio it is
definitely tapping into something the
impact on the conservative leadership
candidates Rivals a black Michigan man
shot dead by a white police officer
Patrick Lee yoya's final moments caught
on camera and the demand for answers
plus Titanic fanatic I was absolutely
captivated one man's lifelong Voyage
devoted to the maritime disaster
[Music]
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Chris gayles good
evening and thank you for joining us
after nearly two weeks of relative calm
loud blasts were once again heard in
Ukraine's Capital Region as Russian
missiles struck a military Factory on
the edge of Kiev the Kremlin claims the
renewed attacks are in response to a
Ukrainian offensive in the East
something Kiev has denied but as the
bombing continues more bodies are being
found in the region every day as
officials inch their way through the
territory left in Ruins by Russian
forces Ukrainian police say more than
900 civilian bodies have now been
discovered in the wake of Russia's
withdrawal from Kiev the majority in the
devastated city of bucha Crystal
gumancing begins our coverage tonight on
a warning some of the images in her
story are difficult to see
from multiple angles multiple missile
strikes caught by security cameras
in the light of day the cleanup begins
and the reality sets in
the attack this man says came out of
nowhere in the middle of the night when
people in the suburb of Kiev were
sleeping
the Kremlin warned Friday it will
increase missile strikes against Targets
in and around the capital following what
it called terrorist attacks on Russian
border communities it also put out new
images highlighting Russia's military
prowess a move possibly to counter
suggestions it has been weakened by the
loss of its prized missile cruise ship
it's now being reported that not
everyone on board survived as Russia
initially stated the ship sank in a
storm following a fire on board
according to the Kremlin Ukraine claims
it fired on the vessel sinking it
fighting has been moving further to the
east as the Kremlin laid out its new
goal of capturing the donbass region the
sound of bombs dropping nearby in this
city where people are loading up cars
with meals rather than their belongings
I stay here because it's my home and we
help people delivering Foods 51 days on
in the Ukrainian sense of Duty remains
strong but there is a cost Ukrainian
officials warn war crimes are being
committed and covered up in the port
city of mariopal it alleges Russian
forces are using mobile crematoriums
City may be close to Falling
For the First Time long-range bombers
are being used in the attacks on the
city says Ukraine's defense Ministry
spokesperson the United States meanwhile
is being urged to stop supporting
Ukraine or face unpredictable
consequences The Washington Post reports
having seen a memo related to a formal
diplomatic note from Russia to the
United States saying it's military aid
is adding fuel to the war
Chris
the gumancing in London thank you
Crystal
the first group of Canadian troops
headed to Poland on a humanitarian
Mission took off from Edmonton this
morning approximately 80 soldiers
boarded a plane to begin a two-month
Mission at Refugee reception centers
throughout Poland another 20 Canadian
Forces members from CFB Trenton will
join that group
the Canadian Conference of Catholic
Bishops says plans for the Pope's visit
to Canada later this year have not been
finalized but Global News has learned
sites in Quebec and Alberta are among
those being considered for survivors of
the residential school system and their
families having the pope visit
indigenous lands is an important step
towards reconciliation and as Heather
York's West reports there are strong
feelings the visit must honor the
children who never came home
[Music]
at St Peter's Basilica Pope Francis
presides over Good Friday services but
behind the scenes planning is well
underway on another sacred event the
Pope's long-awaited visit to Canada as a
child when I was in residential school
and and now
I never thought I'd see the day that
that I like to see the pope coming to
Canada
it's been just two weeks since the head
of the Catholic Church delivered a
surprise apology acknowledging sorrow
and shame for the abuse members of the
church inflicted on children at
residential schools during that speech
Pope Francis also promised to meet with
indigenous families in Canada so that
means a lot to me personally because
it all starts with the truth the
Canadian Conference of Catholic Bishops
says there have been many conversations
to date with indigenous people about
possible sites for the eventual visit
but so far no dates or locations have
been confirmed though Global News has
learned that sites in Quebec and Alberta
are being considered and that to me is
reconciliation survivors like Jennifer
Wood believe the Pope's visit must
include time at the places where
children have been found buried near
residential schools it would be a total
disappointment if he came to our country
and never went to the grounds where the
children were buried and discovered
it would send ripples of disappointment
he needs to acknowledge our pain because
us survivors we are at the school with
those children that they're finding the
children who never came home that many
survivors believe now need to hear the
Pope's words of apology as well
Heather urich's West Global News
Winnipeg
and we'll remind you there is support
for survivors a 24-hour crisis line is
available for anyone experiencing pain
or distress as a result of their or
their loved ones residential school
experience the number is toll-free on
your screen and you can speak in
confidence it's 1-800-721-0066
a new breath test to detect covid-19 is
getting the attention of doctors in
Canada the U.S Food and Drug
Administration has authorized it for
emergency use there and some Canadian
researchers say health Canada should
explore adopting the test here too Ross
Lord shows us why it could be a game
changer even with its limitations
with covid-19 testing becoming routine
there's an innovation that promises to
make it easier a breath test that's
coming soon to a doctor's office near
you if you live or spend time in the
United States the Food and Drug
Administration has okayed the test for
emergency use accepting the developer
inspect IRS test results that show it's
more accurate than rapid tests and is
purported to analyze and show results
screen means negative in about three
minutes it's in a word pretty cool
Canadian doctors like epidemiologist Ray
watt dionandin are intrigued by a test
that's non-invasive and might reduce
transmission rates in key settings so
imagine in front of a daycare center or
a school or a long-term care center or
someone walks in they breathe into the
device the technician looks at it for
about three minutes and says yes you can
come through or you can't come through
there are questions about cost which
neither the FDA nor inspect IR is
advertising the company told Global News
it's not releasing its pricing model at
this time also unclear is what level of
training is required for a technician to
operate the testing machine
and there's a trade-off for that speed
and convenience
so all it says is yes no and that's not
super helpful if we're trying to figure
out where virus is and how it's changing
either Dr Barrett considers the breath
test a potential Niche system for covert
testing not a game changer she says
anything credible that promotes covid-19
testing is worth exploring Health Canada
says it has not yet received an
application for the breath test Ross
Lord Global News
the federal conservatives have banned
the use of prepaid credit cards to
purchase party memberships in a memo to
all campaign teams conservative party
executive director Wayne Benson said the
party will not be accepting prepaid
cards for membership or donations during
the leadership race and it will cancel
all memberships purchased with them
since February 2nd the change comes
after Pierre pauliev's team warned they
could be used to fraudulently buy the
leadership now pauliev's campaign
rallies are attracting some huge numbers
for a leadership race across Canada
thousands are showing up to hear his
message but as David Akin reports
pauliev's challenge will be turning
those crowd numbers into votes foreign
in Edmonton wow
this thousand in Calgary 1500 in
Vancouver a thousand plus in Windsor
Ottawa and other Ontario communities all
crowd estimates but those are
unprecedented numbers for a leadership
race all there to see Ontario MP Pierre
poliev why am I running for prime
minister to put you back in control of
your life by making Canada the freest
Nation on Earth his Rivals dismiss such
slogeneering saying it's taken right
from controversial trucker convoys I
don't think it's all about the trucker
Convoy I think it's about the cost of
living it's about inflation it's about
carbon taxes it's it's the contrast with
Justin Trudeau and it is clear pauliev
is connecting with supporters in a way
few politicians have done uh it's
impressive I mean he's definitely
tapping into something out there and
chamber says Rivals would be foolish to
dismiss the thousands coming to
pauliev's events I think people are
trying to minimize what the polyp
campaign is doing and I think you
humidify is it at your peril he's
definitely tapped into something
outsized crowd sizes can be a sign of an
electorate hungry for change
Justin Trudeau in 2015 just before he
beat Stephen Harper or Jack Layton in
2011 just before the orange wave swept
Quebec as for pauliev's rivals
Ontario MP lesson Lewis has been drawing
a hundred here 200 there Brampton mayor
Patrick Brown will not even tell
journalists about his events his social
media posts show he does have some
supporters and former Quebec Premier
jean-sharay was in Ontario Tuesday where
about 20 showed up for a meet and greet
event there cheray said pauliev is wrong
to side with truck Convoy supporters
he's making a choice that is not only
wrong but is a failure of leadership
ripality of supporters though those
truckers are a feature not a bug can
this win a general election that's a
totally different question that's years
in advance now but I don't know if
anyone can stop this Steamroller up here
pauliev in the leadership
Sheree pauliev and Lewis are the only
ones so far to have raised enough funds
to pay the 300 000 entry fee to become
official candidates the deadline is the
end of the month the vote is in
September David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
Michigan police Under Fire coming up
backlash over the death of a black man
at the hands of a white officer
the world's richest man has been dealt a
major setback in his bid to take over
Twitter Elon Musk owns a nine percent
stake in the social media platform but
he wants to buy the whole thing for 43
billion dollars today Twitter's
directors adopted a shareholder rights
Plan called a poison pill to stop any
hostile takeover the strategy would
flood the market with new and discounted
shares if an individual or group of
masses of 15 percent stake or more in
the company
another community in the U.S is dealing
with a wave of protests and anger after
a white police officer shot and killed a
black man Michigan State Police are
working to determine if the Grand Rapids
officer acted in self-defense or whether
as Jennifer Johnson reports he should
face criminal charges and a warning you
might find the images in this story
disturbing
[Applause]
Grand Rapids Police and City officials
are appealing for calm as protests erupt
after the police involved shooting at
Patrick leoia a refugee from the
Democratic Republic of the Congo the 26
year old was shot in the head by a white
police officer during what was supposed
to be a routine traffic stop the plate
doesn't belong in this car after a brief
exchange the Oya starts to run in a
physical altercation begins Let Go of
the taser at some point the officer's
body cam shuts off police say it
happened from the pressure of the
officer on top of leoia but video
recorded by leoya's Passenger shows the
moment the officer shot him the still
unidentified officer is now on paid
leave Leo's family is in shock
when I saw as a parent when I saw him on
top of him I said okay now my son is
safe maybe he can arrest him the family
who fled violence in Congo is being
represented by the civil rights lawyer
who fought for justice for George Floyd
who died at the hands of Minneapolis
police officers nearly two years ago the
thing that just jumps out at you is how
unnecessary this execution was the
city's police chief is calling the
shooting a tragedy the test is going to
be whether the view of a reasonable
police officer whether that deadly force
was needed to prevent death or great
bodily harm to that officer in the U.S
there are no comprehensive policing
rules when officers are justified in
firing their weapons is determined by
each jurisdiction dozens of states have
enacted police reform laws since Floyd's
murder but the federal George Floyd
Justice and policing Act of 2021 that
would have set National rules and
guidelines failed to pass Congress in
this case it'll be up to County
Prosecutors to determine if charges
should be filed
many African-Americans in Grand Rapids
say they have a long history of not
trusting the police
now the city is bracing for more
protests as residents demand Justice
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
had a very holy time of year more than
150 Palestinians have been injured in
violent clashes with Israeli police at
the Al-Aqsa mosque in Jerusalem
Israeli police fired stun grenades
inside the mosque which is sacred to
Muslims and Jews officers say they
entered the compound to break up a
violent crowd the holy site has been the
epicenter of israeli-palestinian unrest
for decades pretensions are high after a
recent wave of deadly attacks similar
clashes last year sparked an 11-day war
in the Gaza Strip
just ahead super fit athletes still
struggling to outrun their covet
infections
[Music]
with the weather warming up for many
Canadians Runners are lacing up to
prepare for Marathon season but for some
still suffering from the effects of
covid-19 it may not be an even playing
field some Runners are finding it
difficult to pick up training where they
left off Alan Carter reports
I had run 11 marathons and two ultra
marathons running wasn't just part of
Beth Pardo's life it was who she was
then coveted struck in March of 2020.
I've been diagnosed with long covet I've
also been diagnosed with chronic fatigue
syndrome and me which means my level of
activity is severely diminished before
the illness she could push on for
kilometers and kilometers now it's very
difficult for me to grocery shop on
Saturdays I get tired pushing the cart
you know that it's a huge blow for a lot
of high functioning people people with
no medical problems medical research is
just beginning to understand how covet
impacts some people long after their
initial infection when you get infection
it can inflame lots of different blood
vessels in your body the last thing
after effects seem to affect the heart
the lungs it could affect the brain as
well estimates vary widely on how many
people develop long covid although
evidence shows the more vaccine doses
you've had the lower your odds generally
like there are more people running out
than ever before Michael Lynn is head of
the running club that Beth used to be
part of he's managed to evade covid but
says her story is a cautionary tale I
think a good warning to serve some of
the more serious effects of covid it's
very painful for for me to see you know
all my friends on social media who might
be running the races doctors warn not
everyone with long covet will return to
their former self you know most people
will recover most of their function back
that's what we've seen but some people
won't Pardo has seen some improvement in
her condition but wonders if she'll ever
run again I've
designed to the fact that I will
probably deal with these
Alan Carter Global News Toronto
today marks the 110th anniversary of the
RMS Titanic sinking into the Atlantic in
what's considered by many to be the
worst Maritime disaster in history more
than 1500 people died after the luxury
liner struck an iceberg off the coast of
Newfoundland during its maiden voyage
many of the victims were brought to
Halifax and are buried in local
cemeteries there that doomed Voyage has
inspired a number of films extensive
scientific research and its fair share
of enthusiastic fans Dan grummett spoke
to an Edmonton man who has amassed a
large collection of memorabilia and
knowledge along the way
three football fields long she was 12
stories high the story of the Titanic
has fascinated people for Generations
you'd be hard-pressed though to meet
anyone more passionate than this man you
would put your head through
and then just tie it up on the sides
dressed like the doomed ships Captain
Wayne McDonald prefers his title be
Titanic historian Titanic historian
McDonald first became interested at age
six when he heard a first-hand account
of the sinking from a Survivor and from
that moment on I was absolutely
captivated by the story he began
collecting literally anything to do with
the Titanic I've been collecting now for
65 years I probably own almost every
single book that has ever been written
on Titanic those are third class dinner
plates some of his collection is on
display at this West Edmonton antique
store which is marking the anniversary
this week
McDonald says what he loves about the
tragic tale is the range of human
emotion and spirit it encompasses from
Triumph to tragedy heroism to cowardice
there was an amazing response in terms
of how the people aboard Titanic uh
reacted to the realization that they
were not going to be safe it's that
story he's shared repeatedly over the
years as a member of the Titanic
Historical Society there's always
someone with a story for him I wish I
had a dollar for every time someone told
me they had a relative that was going to
travel on the Titanic though much of
what transpired that fateful April night
is known McDonald says there's always
something that emerges from the depths
of History the great thing about Titanic
is I learned something new uh all the
time which is why sharing the story of
the unsinkable ship never gets old Dan
Gromit Global News Edmonton
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm Chris gayles this is an
important period for people of many
faiths so thanks for putting some of
your faith in us tonight's York Canada
is the Alberta town of Crossfield just
north of Calgary we love seeing your
Canada so please email your pictures to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks
very much for watching nitu Garcia will
be with you tomorrow and I'll see you
right back here again on Monday have a
great weekend
thank you